andere russin die sich gegen putin
stellen können nicht den urlaub fahren
sondern wenn sie glück haben ins exil
flüchten so wie ihr gehen ja ehemann ist
in russland eingesperrt sie kämpft in
washington für seine freilassung unserer
amerika korrespondent herbert bauernebel
hat sie dort getroffen
sie kämpft für ein freies russland und
die freiheit ihres mannes jewgenija carr
usa und genau damit könnte sie putin
gefährlich werden uk nord
man kann einen tyrannen nicht
besänftigen man kann ein diktator nicht
besänftigen weil er ein diktator ist ihr
mann ist der journalist und politiker
wladimir carlos a er gilt als einer der
führenden oppositionellen im land hat
zwei vergiftungen überlebt doch russland
zu verlassen kommt für ihn nicht in
frage
russland ist der ort an dem er gebraucht
wird russland ist der ort an dem er
veränderungen herbeiführen will russland
ist der ort an dem er arbeiten will um
das leben für die menschen in russland
zu verbessern jewgenia lebt mittlerweile
mit den drei gemeinsamen kindern in den
usa ihren mann hat sie seit april nicht
mehr gesehen damals verbringen sie ein
paar tage in paris zurück in moskau wird
der putin-kritiker festgenommen
im auto an seinem üblichen parkplatz vor
dem apartment gebäude in dem er lebt als
polizisten auf ihn zuliefen sie zerrt
ihn in einen wenn er hatte die nacht
kein zugang zu einem anwalt keine
möglichkeit uns zu verständigen cara
moser kritisiert russlands krieg gegen
die ukraine scharf in einem interview
sagte er damals zu bild das es nicht
russlands krieg es ist ein
verbrecherisches militärisches abenteuer
eines nicht gewählten autoritären und
zunehmend gestörten diktators namens
putin
jetzt drohen ihm 15 jahre straflager
jewgenia hat angst um ihren mann aber
vor allem ist sie eines wütend
ich denke nicht an angst ich kämpfe für
meinen partner für meinen teamkollegen
für den vater meiner kinder ich denke
nicht an die gefahr ich bin mehr wütend
als ängstlich trotzdem weiß auch seine
frau das russlands diktator vladimir
putin keine gnade zeigt alexei navalny
gehört zu den bekanntesten russischen
dissidenten
2020 überlebt der kreml-kritiker einen
lebensgefährlichen giftanschlag seit
2001 und 20 ist er inhaftiert
ich versuche wladimirs arbeit
fortzusetzen weil sie viel zu wichtig
ist und ich gebe der angst nicht nach
ich denke nicht dass es etwas bringt der
angst nachzugeben und
solange oppositionelle wie evgenia und
ihr mann weiter kämpfen erinnern sie
daran wie viele menschen in russland den
grausamen krieg verabscheuen und für
freiheit einstehen
[Musik]